I guess this week is a Canadian
television host a video game journalist
and a cosplayer most importantly Leon
occurs there welcome to the Reuben
report thanks for having me I thought
maybe you'd be dressed up in some sort
of cosplay type thing maybe just a
little witch or wizard or I I actually
am I'm wearing sort of a steampunk belt
off-camera it is sort of a pirate shirt
oh yeah that's very puffy shirt Seinfeld
sort of yeah yeah it's the French Cups
there's never a time I don't really
separate cosplay from the rest of the
world I do not do the girly stuff well
and so I learned to sort of put outfits
together by following superheroes so if
a superhero can wear a combination of
colors it's okay otherwise I know to
avoid it so there's really no separation
for me that's pretty much how the Big
Bang Theory people address isn't it I've
heard that and I have not seen that
episode I don't watch that show because
I kind of live that show but yeah I've
heard this a few times that they say the
same thing and it it really is true it's
also how I teach color theory it's a
media production interns it's like you
know Superman colors mean good the hero
Joker colors means sort of you know
counterculture so when you're lighting a
set are you're dressing a character that
matters
yeah all right well I do want to get
into some of that stuff but real quick
let's just do cosplay real quick because
I think a certain amount of people have
no idea what it is so first I want you
to define what is but I think you
already said something interesting which
is that it's integrated into your life
all the time usually cosplayers I think
you know they're going around dressing
normally I hate I'm gonna get hate for
that word whatever you want to call it
pressing like ordinary people how about
that and then they have you know they go
to a party or something and dress up but
you're you're integrating bear to thing
yeah yeah I mean my my life is kind of
strange because I'm two people anyway
I'm like this media personality and then
I'm kind of a real person and everybody
in the media
is the reason I went by Leon okay it's
actually a Kafka reference Joseph K from
the trial because you know everyone in
the media is guilty of something we're
just walking around not knowing quite
what it is until they get you one day
but but cosplay is it's a portmanteau of
costume roleplay so basically it started
in a district in Japan not to go too
deep but it's I see it as a way of sort
of embodying the best parts of something
you really like and instead of being an
observer in something sort of being a
third person to sort of experience
something in a very first person way and
I know I just described cosplay in gamer
terms but I'm a big nerd day by kid but
that's basically what it's it's adult
dress up on days that aren't Halloween
right so okay so you you get dressed up
and then you're hanging out with other
people and they're dressed up and are
you're all pretending basically to be
these characters too it's not just that
you're going out and doing the normal
you're actually these people some people
do some people don't I mean I like to
kind of go in between especially with a
villain when there's kids around you
don't want to go full-blown and scare
them but I mean there was a guy one of
these kind of ambush radio guys on a
local radio station and I was wearing
the the Princess Leia bikini from Return
of the Jedi and he came up to me and
started talking me I started responding
in character and you could see the
longer it went on and on and on and on
he thought I was nuts right and it
worked for the purposes of this game
right but you know he was going you know
put some clothes on there's kids around
and I just turned could you guys see my
movie right there like a Princess Leia
and at the end of the interview because
you don't really think you're Princess
Leia do you like no but I started
laughing I mean it actually was a way of
me preserving certain theater skills I
you know improv skills and things like
that that I wasn't able to use when I
started doing other sort
of work so I know other people have
different reasons to get into it but for
me it was this really cool way to
preserve skills because if you don't use
it you lose it
yeah and I hope people don't think that
I'm being judgey about it at all because
I do love and we're gonna get into a lot
of this now
I love nerd culture and sci-fi and geek
stuff and Star Wars I almost learned
everything I know about everything from
Star Wars so I love all that stuff I
just never gone that route but maybe
maybe one day you'll you'll you know
you'll take me to the cosplay place and
we'll play a little cause whenever
you're ready I'll take you there
I've had people over but I will try it I
really will I will at some point all
right so let me just start with
Halloween and make a costume you think
would work at a convention and then if
you're feeling the urge when it's not
Halloween you've already got it yeah but
is it too cliche for me to be a Jedi or
somebody from Star Wars is that just
thought of as like ah yeah another Jedi
Dave I have a life-size Yoda in my house
so the idea that anything related to the
force would be cliche you're really
asking the wrong person I you know live
and breathe Star Wars so
Yodas my boy and I mean if you're more
of a sip in the real world but you're
okay because you trust your feelings so
you could be a Jedi and do it totally on
ironically but I mean I think a lot of
people would go more for Han Solo with
you with look so I mean the cool thing
about cosplay is it the characters
people pick I think are really
informative right I I really miss true
I'll I was playing a lot of man-hating
man hitting Batman villains and it was
sort of a joke because I got into it you
know in late high school and when I was
dealing with a lot of really militant
feminists and I think that was part of
the the coping at the time but it was
definitely working through certain
conflicts liking a lot of male-dominated
stuff you know this ability to do this
really hyper feminine slinky sort of it
permits you to do certain things and you
get a positive response for it when
normally it would be a less slack you
know in that realm you can do it and
and it's contextualized in a way that is
really fun instead of as you said judgy
right best cat woman would you say
Eartha Kitt from the 60s show or
michelle pfeiffer or Halle Berry in
terms of the costume or in terms of the
character I'll give you my answer on
costume first it has to be Michelle
Pfeiffer because that thing yeah that
thing was unbelievable but in terms of
character would you say Oh God because
Eartha Kitt was Eartha Kitt Yeah right
but then I mean Michelle Pfeiffer's
Catwoman for me was such sort of you
know that what they were sort of doing
with that character what Tim Burton did
was something I think I probably more
identified with at the time I mean the
cool thing about making that costume is
I didn't just make the costume I made it
in the same way she did it so I took old
clothes and sort of cut them up and
sewed them back together as sort of a
patchwork so it was it was almost this
really cool process thing but I do admit
I kind of love that purple but my
favorite favorite favorite Catwoman
costume is the Darwin cook rest in peace
redesign that they did in the comic
books with the goggles and the very sort
of Audrey Hepburn inspired look I love
that soup so I can't say that I can
think of that one off the top of my head
but I will do some googling and I'm sure
someone will put the link to it down
below so I was gonna jump into video
games but just going off what you're
saying about Catwoman and that the
Michelle Pfeiffer Catwoman out of those
three probably does fit what you do in
your work the most because she was
really if people remember that was in
Batman Returns the second of the
original Batman she was really a flawed
character and abused by her boss and and
dismissed and she lived in a crappy
apartment and then she became this you
know super sexy empowered woman but was
also a bad guy yet had a certain moral
code so that sort of fits into a lot of
the stuff you talk about with feminism
and I know and all of this and and
cosplay and all this stuff yeah it's
definitely a totem if you will it's
certainly as sort of a patron saint I'm
that whole idea of in a lot of spheres
for women you have a choice you can be
good and ignored or bad and matter and
this dichotomy that you know Michelle
Pfeiffer's Catwoman represented and the
fact that it it requires and this is
like something straight out of an essay
called goodbye doll that by a second why
feminists named Robin Morgan this idea
that a woman in her life at some point
will suffer an insult so great but it's
like that's it that's when you hit I am
Catwoman hear me roar you know it's that
that's will so I got her groove back am
i right
yeah it's that well that's when you get
your groove in the first place right it
was it was never there well it might
have been there when you were born but
then it was very taken from me quite
early but that whole idea that the last
vestige of any pretense to conformity is
gone and I mean yes certainly there is
some conformity of the femme fatale
trope in Catwoman but it is so much her
own thing and I mean you got to remember
that a lot of the Batman stuff does come
above you know rising up in the 1940s
and things like that in that art
direction but it's such a good art
direction so I really don't care it's so
pretty you know and some it was a period
that in its images really celebrated the
feminine gender signifiers
for lack of a better term and now we're
not so good at that we're not so good at
just going that is a representation of
the feminine awesome without looking to
tear it down yeah so what do you make of
that concept though that when she got
her green back when she became Catwoman
from this flawed sort of quiet demure
woman she then was a bad guy and even
though as I said in that movie at least
there were good elements to her too and
she sort of became a good person you
know a good guy at the end but that too
once she got her thing she now was
thought of as a villain
well now you're getting kind of academic
on me your trigging my English
literature background she's officially
an antique
so in the tradition of Lord Byron and
there are very few female anti-heroes
and media and that's why she's so
important Lara Croft used to be one not
so much anymore but you know the
antihero is important because if you
remember you know you take the movie
there was a villain that villain was the
penguin and the Christopher Walken
character was definitely villainous she
was an antihero and so anti-heroes
Severus Snape is an antihero you know
it's all about characters that have the
role of a hero but have non heroic
elements to them and they're very very
popular with male characters but women
it's much fewer and far between and
that's part of the reason I really like
her I think more and more a lot of the
Batman
the Gotham girls as they say could be
described as anti-heroes poison ivy goes
back and forth she can be the villain
one minute and then sort of an antihero
when it's her and Harley Quinn Harley's
the same way she started as sort of the
the Joker's Moll but more and more she's
become this character that the plot
revolves around and this idea of hero
and villain is structural right it's
who's telling the story and it's
sometimes the story is told from the
point of view of the villain but it's
very rare when you hit that protagonist
role it's usually an antihero yeah you
know as you're saying this it's
reminding me of if we can jump can we
jump from from DC to Marvel for a second
can you jump with me I'm big on tangents
alright it reminds me sort of of the of
the origin story of magneto because you
know he grows up and he loses his
parents in the Holocaust I think it's at
Auschwitz and if you see the movies they
show the you know the gates closing and
the whole the whole thing and then
because he was so scarred he becomes a
villain and it's actually it's sort of
similar she was scarred for other
reasons and became a villain and that
antihero
I think magneto is the most interesting
person in all of those movies because of
that because you see that constant fight
between knowing what he's been through
and trying to get you know revenge but
revenge will never actually satiate the
the pain III think those are the most
interesting characters yeah I mean you
got to remember when X
than was created Stanley was really
cheeky about some of the names I mean
the fact that you know making it a sort
of antihero counterpart mystique there's
a reason she was called mystique it's
from Betty for Dan's book the feminine
mystique and the fact that she can morph
into all these things Magneto it's funny
but he sort of become this gay icon
because to me I sort of you know the
fact that he was Jewish was so relevant
to me and you know speaking to some
older people who remember the Holocaust
and all that stuff that anger that he
embodies and that that righteous anger
and that kind of idea that humanity's
done we are superior and you know we
have to assume a superior status for the
good of humanity they'll serve us well
when they recognize our superiority it's
a very human tendency and I'd love to
write Magneto's guide to the regressive
left in the all right I mean it it would
be such a cool book we can collab on
that one absolutely it it really is that
idea of extremism and where it comes
from and you know using a Jewish
character and then giving him giving him
names like the Brotherhood of mutants
and naming mutants homo superious and
and things like that and now this is
really nerdy but I know all this stuff
no I'm with you yeah yeah you've you've
got he's one of my favorite characters
as well and I mean just the fact that he
had that flowing hair as well and it he
was really a mess of contradictions and
the the sheer power and being able to
control magnetism as well you know x-men
wasn't a metaphor for fear of people who
were different straight-up
yes sort of informed by the the various
civil rights struggles of the 1960s but
that's what it was about just the
inherent fear of people who are
different you have you know the mutants
being you know
trying to protect this group of people
who hates and fears them God that's my
mantra when I get out of bed some
mornings but then you had the mutants
fighting each other and it was
practically predictive of what's going
on right now but I think it was actually
observing what was going on at the time
with the splintering within the civil
rights movement within the second wave
feminist movement within these movements
that's the cool thing about pop culture
is it observes what's going on in our
world through a lens that is far enough
away then it can really go in deep
without freaking everyone out and the
fact that the big properties of our time
are The Hunger Games and Harry Potter
that's gonna be dissected at some point
I mean that really says a lot about our
collective cultural experience yeah so
all that said would you say that just
because of the breadth of work and the
relevance of it that x-men has sort of
pulled off the comic book thing in terms
of culture in the best way I mean when I
was a kid I you know I loved comic books
but I was more into spider-man and
Batman and GI Joe x-men was not huge for
me but I've come to love you know even
from those cartoons in the I guess
mid-90s or so that that x-men because of
the reasons that you're talking about
the way it really dealt with some and
deals with some real-world stuff and the
way that the movies have all sort of
amazingly linked back and forth to each
other in in really crazy ways that it is
sort of because of its cultural
relevance and the success of the
franchise is that that that's the
standout one that the x-men the x-men
has had it's been incredibly influential
but the 90s x-men cartoon and the x-men
movies people have to remember before
this whole Marvel Universe thing before
the whole Avengers think there was x-men
before there was Batman the Animated
Series you know that became this big
there was x-men and so it's been this
break her down of boundaries between
geek culture and pop culture in a way
that I don't think gets enough credit
because we we couldn't
have these blockbuster you know Disney
Marvel films were it not for the success
of those x-men films I mean at the time
they came out that was a big risk right
it wasn't a popular time because we had
the Schumacher Batman films and
everything was going kitschy but they
really and I'm obviously Batman the
Animated Series had a lot to do with the
respectability of superheroes as well
but on the film side you know the x-men
films and spider-man were the big ones
but I really think credit goes to two
x-men for showing that it can be done I
mean showing that it can create stars
showing that it's not a junk part those
are all really really important things
that first film did that star war you
know star wars did in a much bigger way
back in the 70s and things like Lord of
the Rings have done it's it's powerful
because people don't go in and overthink
it and I love that about it people go in
there and watch a good movie yeah and if
that you know if they walk away with a
few pro-social messages awesome but
that's not the purpose of the exercise
they can walk away and be just as
brain-dead as they were than they go in
it doesn't matter right people were
entertained and that's right yeah that's
really interesting because I just
watched the last x-men movie apocalypse
like a week ago and I thought it was
great and what I think what I really
thought was great about it was that it
was at you know action and fun and all
that and it gave you a little something
but that I could follow the plot where
most of these movies even though I dig
this stuff I'm like at by the end the
last half hour I'm always like what just
happened or you know that terrible
Batman I don't know what you thought
about Batman Superman but that thing was
a disaster so you're right that giving
you just enough and to walk out of there
with maybe something that sparks a
little something any of that's I guess
that's the Batman versus Superman was a
perfect example of a movie that tried to
make a point all caps as opposed to just
tell a story and humans relate to humans
and this is a huge thing in in all my
work that humans relate to humans and
if first and foremost in fiction you're
not telling a human story about a
particular individual or group of
individuals then you're writing a
textbook you're not telling the work of
fiction and it is gonna fail especially
in our current culture where people are
so media savvy or perceived themselves
to be so media savvy they can smell that
coming I mean this was what I learned in
youth programming the so-called
millennial generation they will kick
your butt if you don't seem authentic
and I think that's a good thing for the
public discourse
in the long term I just think it's
gotten exceptionally loud now because of
the part of the short term loss of faith
in systems
you